[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur ou madame
j'aime bien votre gueule c'est comme ça
que j'aborde les inconnus que je
photographie dans les rues de paris
à mi chemin entre photographe et poète
j'arpente les boulevards les rues et les
moindres ruelles à la rencontre des
personnalités atypiques qui font de
paris une ville magique
je les appelle mais gueule de parisiens
gueule de parisiens c'est un blog un
journal urbain qui raconte en photos et
en mots et parisien suivi par des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
j'ai exposé à l'hôtel de ville de paris
et aujourd'hui je travaille avec les
marques pour raconter les humains qui
font avancer de monde
si je suis ici ce soir c'est pour vous
raconter comment cette aventure a
commencé et jusqu'où elle est d'aller
nous sommes le 3 janvier 2012 je viens
d'acquérir mon premier vrai appareil
photo vous avez industeel manuel avec
des fonctionnalités et des boutons à
l'appel je ne sais pas encore mais c'est
un objet mystique qui sera bientôt de
mise
je le range dans ma valise et oui demain
je m'envole pour philadelphie moi c'est
fn
étudiante en école de commerce je
m'apprête pour la première fois de ma
vie a quitté le nid et à partir en
échange universitaire aux états unis là
bas je découvre un système d'éducation
qui fait la part belle à l'exploration
être étudiant en commerce ne m'empêche
pas de prendre des cours de journalisme
et de photographies alors je me lance
plein d' enthousiasme dans ces deux
disciplines qui vont changer ma vie
assoiffé d'image à capturer et
d'histoires à raconter
j'écume le campus je prends des photos
sous tous les angles et j'interpelle
tous les étrangers
et puis les mois passent et je me lasse
jusqu'au jour où je croise cet homme
dont le regard me transperce
son histoire m'intéresse lui c'est bine
bill ça fait plus de vingt ans qu'il
travaille sur le campus
avec lui on a voyagé dans le temps vingt
ans en arrière à l'époque où la
bibliothèque où je passe mes nuits
n'était qu'un parking et mon bâtiment
d'études en terrain vague mal famé et
puis sans rien forcé c'est son histoire
personnelle que bill a commencé à me
livrer son destin 10 à celui de
l'université l'histoire de son fils
qu'il a perdu et qu'il s'est tatoué pour
la voir avec lui à jamais en 3 clics ça
a été le déclic
bill c'était mon premier choc ma
première rencontre
mon premier vrai portrait il m'a révélé
ma première vérité mettre des photos en
poésie voilà de quoi j'ai vraiment envie
seulement bientôt philadelphie il me
suffit plus j'en veux plus je veux plus
de frénésie plus de bruit plus d'autrui
alors je prends le bus direction new
york city là bas je rencontre des
personnalités farfelues comme je n'en
avais jamais vu je déjeune avec le sosie
de woody allen
je joue au basket avec des gangsters à
harlem tout ça bien sûr toujours avec
des inconnus
ce sont ces rencontres qui m'ont inspiré
mon premier projet d'avis aide
john challenger mon père m'a dit de ne
pas parler aux étrangers en hommage à
mon papa
rouge de colère et surtout vert de peur
de voir ce que fait sa fille de six
heures et puis c'est le retour à paris
mon essence se finit et moi je range mon
appareil photo bien au fond d'un tiroir
guidé par cette petite voix intérieure
qu'on appelle la peur c'est elle qui me
murmure stéphanie les états unis c'est
bien joli mais tata qui au parisien
l'enfant t'es pas bien et cette voie je
les écoute
ce qu'à mon arrivée chez mylittleparis
my little paris c'est un média digital
qui recommandent tous les bons plans de
la capitale moi je suis rentré là bas en
tant que stagiaire commercial mais je
vais vous faire une confession ma
passion c'était plutôt de traîner avec
les filles de la rédaction
alors quand un beau jour j'entends qu'un
blog photo d'un genre nouveau est dans
les tuyaux
je saute sur l'opportunité pour porter
le projet c'est comme ça que gueule de
parisiens est né
les filles de malitel parisse m'ont
donné des ailes et je ne me serais
jamais lancé 100 m
je n'aurais jamais rencontré igor la
montagne cet indien croisé dans le métro
ou odette et louise mes demoiselles de
rochefort que j'ai photographié en train
de se disputer
je n'aurais jamais suivi aurélie pendant
plusieurs centaines de mètres avant
d'oser l'aborder je capture
tous parlent des touristes émerveillés
aux icônes emblématiques de quartier en
passant quand même par quelques
parisiens blasé pendant plusieurs années
je transforme les passants en héros et
je les fait vivre sur mes réseaux
sociaux et à travers mes expos nous
sommes maintenant le 2 mai 2016 je me
brosse les dents et mon téléphone se met
à vibrer je viens de recevoir un e-mail
pour intervenir à la sorbonne et parler
d'engagement citoyen et de créativité
engagement citoyen mois google de
parisiens pour tout vous dire au début
je ne comprends pas de là je sais que
mes portraits peuvent faire sourire
voire rire mais de là à parler d'une
démarche engagée
et pourtant trois semaines plus tard je
suis devant mon auditoire qui me prouve
que oui oui ma poésie peut être un
formidable vecteur d'empathie l'audience
est captivé mon doute élevé et surtout
ce soir là j'ai trouvé mon rôle à jouer
dans la société être artisan d'histoire
et libérer leur pouvoir raconter les
hommes et les femmes avec mon regard
ce soir là j'ai compris que la rencontre
c'est ce choc pendant lequel l'autre
vous tant le miroir de soi ce miroir se
sont jules et jonas qu ils entendus pour
moi les étudiants qui m'ont invité
ils ont compris avant tout le monde et
surtout avant moi ce que je devais faire
de ma voix alors
convaincu de ma nouvelle mission je pars
dans une nouvelle épopée à la recherche
d'histoires à raconter
j'ouvre les yeux et je constate que ma
ville a changé et aujourd'hui je veux
raconter les histoires de ce que les
médias appellent des réfugiés alors
appareil en main et avec mon client
toujours je suis parti à la recherche de
ces parisiens qu'on ne connaît pas bien
ensemble nous avons vécu des moments
légers eu des sourires complices et nous
avons partagé par les de paris qui
envers et contre tous reste une fête
ils se sont aussi livrés à moins avec
beaucoup de courage
et aujourd'hui je voudrais vous raconter
une histoire pour leur rendre hommage
je voudrais vous présenter des eaux
sa majesté des eaux des eaux et réfugiés
de la république démocratique du congo
quand nous nous sommes rencontrés il m'a
tout raconté des eaux et journaliste il
dénonce le massacre de ses frères et la
corruption
il reçoit des menaces mais continue à
dénoncer
jusqu'au jour où des eaux est en voyage
à l'étranger et il comprend qu'il est
coincé des eaux et réfugiés ce voyage
c'était en france qui le faisait et la
france c'est un pays que des oem parce
qu'il est champion du congo zaïre
d'orthographe et le langue française
depuis 1990 est titulaire d'une plume
d'or de littérature des eaux
il aime les mots et je dois dire qu'il
me coiffe au poteau
quand nous avons échangé il m'a raconté
qu'il a tout fait pour s'intégrer il a
accepté les jobs les moins qualifiés
pour prouver comme il dit qu'il n'est
pas un connard de noir et pourtant quand
je lui parle de racisme
il me sourit et me dit
stéphanie g pas vécu le racisme mais
j'ai vécu l'ignorance oui et toi qui
aime les histoires écoute bien celle là
un jour j'étais sur le quai du métro une
maman et sa fille sont à côté de man et
la petite se précipite et commence à me
frotter le bras elle fera t-elle fera t
elle se retourne vers sa maman elle dit
maman je ne comprends pas
j'essaie de le laver mais il est
toujours noir sam elle accourt vers des
eaux se confond en excuses et lui il lui
répond mais madame ne vous en faites pas
ce geste c'est simplement l'innocence
d'une enfant et cette histoire c'est
bien plus qu'une simple anecdote c'est
du 100% des eaux
c'est la noblesse de son âme en
filigrane
après avoir plongé dans la réalité bien
ancrée des personnes réfugiées
je suis parti avec d'autres réalités à
explorer je me suis plongé dans ce mythe
urbain que vous connaissez bien
très présent dans nos quotidiens à tous
et surtout à tout
la parisienne vous savez ce mythe du bon
goût et de l'élégance à qui il faudrait
à tout prix ressembler et pourtant moi
ce que j'ai constaté c'est que nous
sommes nombreuses à être parisienne et
pour les univers médiatique nous sommes
trop trop petit trop grosse trop moche
trop vieille et surtout trop peu
d'artistes qui remettent en question cet
esthétisme ultra glamour is an et ça
pour moi c'était révoltant alors
accompagné d'un collectif
nous avons créé et vilaine parisienne
pour mettre sur le devant de la scène
tout des parisiennes nous avons exposé
aux folies bergères et montrer à des
centaines d'hommes et de femmes la
féminité dans toute sa diversité
certainement un petit choc pour certains
et moins en rencontrant ses parisiennes
j'ai questionné la femme que je voulais
vraiment incarné les moins et les années
passent et je me demande ce que je veux
bien faire de ce projet est-ce que je
dois me professionnaliser
je réalise quelques rêves en chemin
j'expose à l'hôtel de ville de paris
l'écrin parfait pour mes parisien et
pourtant c'est toujours le désert
créatif
jusqu'au jour où jules vous savez le jul
de la sorbonne réapparait avec mon
premier brief professionnels un projet
pour donner à voir le monde paysan sous
un jour différent
il n'en fallait pas plus il a dissipé
les doutes remis ma machine créative en
route et cette petite voix autrefois
sous le signe de la peur me murmure
cette fois ci allait stéphanie vas-y je
me lance et je crée mon agence votre
petit rat des villes est donc parti à la
rencontre des rats des champs et cette
fois j'ai embarqué avec moi mon papa des
maraîchers des agriculteurs des éleveurs
je suis parti à la rencontre du monde
paysan
une communauté qui demande un respect
qu'on lui doit et qu'elle mérite de
protéger la terre que l'on habite
j'ai rencontré nathalie et sa grelinette
vincent et son tracteur
clémentine et benoît avec leurs moutons
mais aussi marion et ses potirons
ils sont impressionnants et moi je crois
que dans un monde obsédé par la
technologie colonisée par les fermes de
serveurs
il est grand temps de remettre les
fermes de nos paysans à l'honneur et de
célébrer leur valeur ils sont fiers ils
sont beaux et moi aussi je suis fier de
porter leur flambeau le message que je
voudrais vous faire passer ce soir c'est
que nous vivons dans un monde
déstabilisant sans cesse en mouvement
personne n'est vraiment préparé personne
ne sait gérer et pourtant tout le monde
peut jouer un rôle pour une humanité
plus connectés moi je le fais avec cet
objet révélateur d'autrui et chambre
noire de soi alors à vous à vous de
trouver votre objet votre clé votre
boussole et partez partez en voyage
initiatique
prenez ce que le destin met entre vos
mains et explorer vous verrez il n'y a
pas besoin de partir loin pour voyager
et surtout surtout dans votre valise
n'oubliez jamais de porter vos valeurs
celles du cac et du sourire merci
[Applaudissements]